welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of house of
the dragon episode 4 in which this
series defies game of thrones tradition
of normalizing incest by
wow but did it actually happen in this
story told by unreliable narrators
yeah of but does that even matter if the
maesters hook you up with that good old
plan t let's do what we do here in new
rockstars and go deeper into the visuals
than anyone else cares too and exposes
deeper layers of meaning that you might
have overlooked in this episode starting
with a very easy to miss update to the
opening title sequence the bloodline
around allison's dial which last week
was updated to now meet viserys's
bloodline now in episode 4 branches
downward but doesn't yet touch the dial
below the opening shot shows a valyrian
steel necklace that demon gabriel nira
the symbol that's been on renera's dial
and notice how she fondles it for
shadowing the suitor that she really
wants to fondle this episode i'm sorry
other suitors line up to propose to
renera we see one from house frey that's
a sigil of the twins there's a house
tully fish behind him and then how
strong meanwhile the old man speaking
according to the captions is named
barrick dundarian who of course is not
the lightning lord from game of thrones
era but this earlier lord danderian says
[Music]
the castle
is surrounded by a deep
dry emote
it is well fortified against any future
dawnish incursions
yes black haven is the home of house
danderian in the stormlands to the west
where dornish incursions would be a big
issue actually this is likely the same
lord dundarian to whom sir kristen
cole's father served as steward this is
before kristin fought in some of those
dornish incursions that rumble of
thunder that we hear tells us that we
are at storm's end the home of house
baratheon actually that's lord berman
baratheon sigil of the stag seated
beside rhaenyra the baratheons and
targaryens at this point in history are
pretty good friends with lord aorus
baratheon becoming the hand to egg on
the conqueror the young lord blackwood
scholar shows two ravens actually that
house is sigil is a flock of raven
surrounding a dead weirwood tree he says
his house descends from the first men
the first men being one of the three
ethnic groups from whom westeros humans
descended along with the rhoynar and the
andals the first men formed the pact
with the children of the forest and
adopted the children of the force old
gods thus the weirwood tree in the
blackwood sigil lord blackwood claims
that his family helped egg on the
conqueror referring to house blackwood
siding with aegon when he torched
harrenhal and conquered the riverlands
as we saw in the series opening scene
towards dragonfire that killed this
beast so yeah young lord blackboard is
trying to ride some coattails and
bullying him is lord bracken notice the
red stallion of house bracken the
blackwoods and the brackens have long
hated each other actually in the text
samwell blackwood and amos bracken duel
for reniers affection but during her
visit to the trident turns out this
blackwood is not samwell blackwood hbo
confirmed it is willem of blackwood and
i think they changed the setting of the
stool because they wanted to establish
storm's end as an important location for
major events later in the series and for
all you book readers out there it does
make us wonder will faded duels at
storm's end go down the same way in this
series as they do in the book but that's
a question for like season three anyway
blackwood totally defeats bracket here
so points on the board for the blood of
the first men just an interesting
recurring theme on the series so far
that indigenous westerosi virtues
weirwood trees the white heart first men
bloodlines seem to bear more strength
than the currently more valued virtues
like dragons and valyrian blood there's
probably some metaphor here in invaders
colonialism and imperialism but i'll let
you draw those conclusions a little
detail i love as bracken spews up blood
little blackwood takes in his first kill
and he looks like he's about to vomit
don't worry kid i often feel the same
way oh by the way epicurean merch is a
new shirt ash and ruin which you can get
at epihurshop.com karaxi's shoulder
checks the boat you can actually spot
damon writing on karaxi's back there so
he did this on purpose and rhaenyra
smiles as if to say challenge accepted
uncle we see a close-up of zerus crown
underlying the significance of crowns in
this setting and how wearing anything
resembling a crown is an affront to the
monarch viserys dons this and carries
blackfyre the valerian steel sword of
aegon the conqueror ronira enters with
this eager crowd and notice how she
tries to hide herself behind the
onlookers but viserys does notice her
arrival we see the moment he frowns
because yeah rainier still had another
two months on this suitor tour that he
spent all his time arranging for her
damon enters the room for the first time
since he was banished in episode one
with shorter hair and a crown made of
wood carrying the hammer of craig as the
crab feeder raniere follows him through
the crowd as he approaches the king
setting up her following this pied piper
uncle throughout this episode but demon
offers the hammer to viserys add it to
the chair
the iron throne is of course composed of
weapons wielded against the targaryens
but in a way this is also a kind of
insult to viserys as this hammer would
be a more blunt instrument less likely
to cut the curse king than all the
swords he keeps cutting himself on and
at first damon keeps them guessing in
this loyalty once we smash the trio key
they name me king of the narrow sea
but i know that there is only one true
king your grace but demon ultimately
offers viserys crown as if it's a
meaningless honorary thing that was
given to him by others but notice that
massive ruby wired to the front of the
crown targaryens regularly adorn their
pieces with rubies ruby's on rainier is
necklace ruby's on the conqueror's crown
so damon clearly made this crown himself
in the fashion of the conqueror the
crown that vizera said was in his dream
so this is a total power move by daemon
it's meant to insult viserys but viserys
lets it go and hugs his brother and
notice how the bottom two glove fingers
again fold emptily just another example
of patty considine doing some limp glove
work to show how his ring and pinky
fingers have withered off in the garden
analysis suggests perhaps prince damon
would care for a tour of the gallery he
hasn't yet seen any tapestries gifted to
you by novus and cohort norvos and
kohora are the two inland-free cities of
essos meaning they weren't part of that
maritime triarchy and likely wanted to
curry favor with the crown to separate
them from mere lease and tirosh i
actually wonder if noro seguro could be
the one supplying those horny bestiality
tapestries that covered the red key
ronira and damon discuss royal marriages
for men versus women and bring up
damon's current wife ria royce in the
veil
[Music]
total
despite damon's reputation as a
womanizer this series has so far only
ever shown him as impotent it was not
working with missouri on episode one he
lied about her being pregnant in episode
two ria royce is without child and he
struggles with renera in this episode so
is damon's impotency a temporary
obstacle that he's meant to overcome in
the series or a tragic curse that he's
destined to doom himself on in a series
of bad choices in this scene damon seems
to suggest it's the latter okay simon
dies my voice rainer's chat with allison
earlier about being trapped in a castle
with screaming children having to
squeeze out more children is shown in
the middle part of this episode
meanwhile with ronira the girl goes wild
starting with damon's notre nera written
in high valyrian this is a written form
of this language developed by the
linguist in this series and of game of
thrones david j peterson the guy who
also came up with the ins and outs of
dothraki and while he based the spoken
language of valyrian partly on latin
when it comes to the written form he
went in a different direction because
notice how unlike english writing which
uses a glyph for each consonant and
vowel high valyrian is a logographic
system in which a single glyph can
represent an entire word at a recent
expo peterson actually said they
developed 365 unique glyphs for this
series now i do not know all 365 of
those glyphs but by looking at
peterson's instagram posts it looks like
the third and fourth line of this note
that damon wrote renera have part of his
glyph for the word brick which is likely
an instruction to push a specific brick
to open the secret passageway and yes i
have been pointing out how damon is the
master of stinks who knows all the
secret passageways that his ancestor bag
or the cruel had constructed in the red
keep and then killed off on the
construction workers to keep that secret
and now according to this drawing this
passageway opens up in rainer's bedroom
right beside her bed and if your uncle
telling you that it's not creepy to you
i i don't know what it will be so renera
passes through the basement containing
the skull of valerian the black dread a
close-up of its teeth shows some mice
nibbling showing how various sets of
eyes are going to be on ronira tonight
that she is not aware of actually later
alison sees a mouse on a bedpost
signaling that these passages from the
royal quarters to the tunnels below are
open and she's missing out on the fun
damon rainier strolled in the city
intercut with the shots of a burst of
flames from a metal dragon head this is
the one that's actually used in the
alley that leads to the corner where the
mummers are doing their play ronero
passes a blind woman who offers to tell
her her death to renera this woman would
be the literal form of the crone one of
the seven and when you pair this with
all these recurring shots of dragon fire
i don't know that might be part of her
nearest future we get this moment with
viserys and allison at the bath
initially parallel with viserys and emma
at the bath the bath precedes the fall
because notice here he has cuts and
wounds all over his arms and shoulders
and back likely each of them different
cuts from the swords of the iron throne
when viserys later makes her join him in
his chamber we see his entire back and
it's now covered in festering scabs so i
stare at screens all day and that can be
tough on my eyes it used to be the case
that i'd help my eyes out by wearing a
pair of blue blocks blue light glasses
but blue blocks has now become a bond
charge thankfully the glasses stayed the
same bond charges a couple different
glasses depending on what you need my
go-to are the computer glasses they help
reduce sore eyes headaches watery eyes
and fatigue if i'm staring at a computer
all day or if i'm in a room with
fluorescent lights these glasses are my
first line of defense bond charges
glasses are backed by science and tested
to make sure they work which is not the
case with other light blocking glasses
on the market if you've got a
prescription you can get these with a
prescription if you don't you can still
get these without a prescription if you
just need a pair of light blocking
reading glasses bon charge can handle
that too bond charge ships worldwide and
have other great products like low blue
light bulbs red light therapy devices
and 100 light blocking sleep masks go to
bondcharge.com new rockstars and use
coupon code new rockstars to save 20
percent that's
b-o-n-c-h-a-r-g-e dot com slash new
rockstars and use the coupon code new
rockstars to save 20 reneer and damon
watch this play satirizing their current
royal succession drama the demon actor
is mostly shown in the background of the
scene reacting the way daemon in the
series is lurked in the shadows saying
very little and you'll notice how all
the actors are male which was a
tradition in real world elizabethan
times but a contrast with the mummers
that we meet in game of thrones 200
years later in essos the city of braavos
the troop that includes the actress lady
crane ronero mirrors arya stark a lot in
this episode dressing as a boy and
sneaking out of the red keep through the
same tunnels that arya did and like arya
when she saw that mummer's play in
braavos this highborne lady is learning
the oversimplified truth of how the
common folks see all this royal drama
it's not exactly what they'd expect as
she runs ronira runs into the captain
the city watch sir harwin strong so
holmen
princess
don't
you take care boy
next time you might not be so lucky you
remember sir harwin he joined the hunt
in episode three and gave her an error
that approving grin when she returned
with the slain boar now in her private
quarters the bed that alison sleeps in
is the literal same bed and headboard of
the bed that queen emma died in now it's
understandable that allison would have
the same room but they couldn't change
out the bed come on why would you do
that to allison now thanks to youtube we
won't be showing or really describing
most of the sexual imagery in the
brothel sequence but director claire
kilner to describe how she tried to
shoot the sex scenes of this episode
from renera's point of view as opposed
to from the male point of view which
traditionally is how a lot of sex scenes
have been shot so you'll notice as this
intercuts with allison we actually spend
most of the run time on close-up
reactions from renera and allison and
they're contrasting excited and bored
expressions the sex that both of them
are experiencing is really framed
through the way they're emotionally
processing it but really including
renera and damon's hookup at all in this
show is hugely important because it
lends a bit of objectivity to something
that was in the text presented as
unreliable gossip from the account of a
mummer named mushroom but notice how
this scene is shot with hardly any
lighting and really a lack of clarity
over how far exactly it goes downstairs
like if you re-watch the scene yourself
not here you'll notice that damon does
lower raniere's trousers he presses
himself against her but there's no like
thrusting and soon after that she just
turns around and takes the reins and her
advances and that's when damon totally
disengages so it's tough to watch this
scene at first glance and well it's
actually just tough to watch a period
but it is difficult to watch a scene
once and come out of it with a clear
understanding of how far these two
actually went therefore in the context
of this brothel any witness to this
hookup couldn't truly testify with
certainty over how far it went either so
that way this series you could say
maintains the unreliable narrator
element from the book all we know is
that this uncle and niece definitely
went too far but that only the two of
them actually know how far it really
went and then afterward each of them
made separate decisions on how to
recount that truth to others i feel like
i'm gonna get a lot of emails yelling at
me for that one i'm just saying i don't
think anyone who watched that scene for
the first time could look at that
horrible lighting and say i know exactly
what happened there now we see this
shaggy-haired boy outside who follows
rhaenyra he was likely also among those
peepers on damon and mazzaria in episode
one part of the network who reported to
otto that damon called balon air for a
day something that we also did not see
damon objectively saying on screen but
he took credit for anyway ronira goes
home and seduces sir kristin which is
also an alteration from the unreliable
account that's in the book which claims
that damon coach renera into seducing
sir kristen but here it is fully renear
his own choice and that's proven with i
think my favorite detail of this episode
the next morning after sleeping with sir
kristen and for the rest of the episode
notice how rainier has now switched out
the valerian steel necklace that damon
gave her the one that she was touching
in the opening shot now she shelves that
necklace and has reverted to a simpler
golden necklace because she no longer
needs damon to have power in this
episode now otto meets with that
shaggy-haired boy whom we learn as a
messenger from someone called the white
worm and this same boy in the next scene
passes money to mazzaria and she is
dressed in a slender white gown so it is
confirmed mazzaria is the white worm
otto's primary contact who has been
passing auto intel on damon with the
help of these child spies like varys and
like qyburn she has a league of little
birds which makes sense because this
character will go on to become a master
of whispers i like this shot where
damon's blindness to her is reflected
with the blinding sunlight behind azaria
as she hands him the hangover team now
despite all this we still do not know if
missouri's reports are objectively true
or just some salacious gossip that
paints damon in its scandalous light and
damon just doesn't deny any of it
actually one could argue that damon
knows mazaria is feeding this gossip to
otto and allows it to happen knowing
that otto will spill this tea to viserys
embarrassing the king and forcing otto
to admit that he is using spies which
makes him look pretty bad which would
ultimately force viserys to choose
between his hand and his brother which
damon might have plotted to remove both
himself and otto as morally corrupt
equals really it comes down to how smart
do we think damon is i don't know he may
just be a self-destructed pratt but i
just love the way matt smith plays this
with such cryptic glances very few words
and the way this character's written
just own up to the things that would
hurt his brother the most otto mentions
the hour of the owl calling back the
dragon keeper's reference to the hour of
the bat in episode two so the hours
through the night go after sunset the
hour of the bat an hour they healed and
the hour of ghosts then the hour of the
owl then the hour of the wolf and then
the hour of the nightingale so in the
godswood the scene with rainier and
allison my favorite scene of the episode
because rhaenyra responds perfectly to
the accusation she admits to drinking
into partying with damon but when it
comes to having sex with him she feigns
disgust this
is a vile
accusation
is it you targaryens do have queer
customs and damon certainly knows no
limit alison
your grace sister you must know i would
i would never
you're gonna believe such gossip i love
the contrasting communication compared
to these two in the previous episode
because in episode three rainier cold
shoulder the queen in the same location
but now rhaenyra comes to her appealing
to her by name and then by her formal
title your grace and then through their
sisterhood companionship and as ronira
did when she was making out with her
uncle she so deftly shifts first from
the defensive but then to the aggressor
my father is no gossip well suddenly
he's been mislead he could not have
witnessed such a thing why not because
it did not happen he was told
ah and ramirez catches allison for
basing this on an anonymous third person
account one that alison was not even
supposed to hear she was eavesdropping
dropping ease so raniera knowing she has
her crosses behind her closer to the
judging stare of the eyes of the
weirwood tree she is literally on the
higher ground now like a judge in a
courtroom in this way if you think about
it raining her also avoids having to
herself look in the eyes of the weirwood
tree because she is totally lying
through her teeth in the scene i am the
princess to
to question my virtue is an act of
treason yes and now by turning the
tables on the queen ramirez has control
over the conversation and she can feed
allison whatever version of the events
that she wants and nelson will be forced
to at least hear her out meanwhile damon
takes a very different strategy against
the accusations she's just a girl
your niece there is a woman grown better
first experience would be with me than
some [ __ ] i want rhaenyra i'll take her
as she is in weathering the tradition of
our house yeah so damon totally owns it
but he also lies just on the other side
of the truth he lies about his imminency
he claims that he fully did the deed and
why he does it to enrage his brother and
to make a power play bizarre shows
renera how aegon's dagger contains
glyphs hidden by pyromancers in the
valyrian steel from my blood
come the prince that was promised
and his will be the song of ice and fire
this inscription officially merges the
two prophecies in game of thrones that
we all pretty much assumed were
referring to the same thing at this
point we learned in episode one that the
targaryen belief in the song of ice and
fire was something passed down from
targaryen ruler to targaryen ruler for
mega on the conqueror maybe even before
but the prince that was promised
referred to a prophecy from believers in
the lord of light azor ahai reborn the
wielder of lightbringer who would
vanquish the darkness melisandre
initially believed it would be stannis
baratheon but then when stannis died she
then thought it was jon snow mimo
daenerys learned that the high valyrian
word for prince was actually gender
neutral and believed that she could be
the princess that was promised game of
thrones final season arguably
deprioritizes these prophecies while
john and danny were important to the
defeat of the white walkers arya cast
the killing blow and neither john nor
dany sat on the iron throne during this
war so i don't know maybe george r
martin has different plans for the
ending of his a song of ice and fire
novels that he's trying to set up in
this series but either way the
description in this dagger proves that
the root of those two strands of the
same prophecy were really the same the
pyromancers of valyria and aegon his
grandfather anar the exile who was one
who fled valeria with his family after
the dreams of his daughter danny's the
dreamer and who knows how far back that
dagger goes but wherever it was that
route inspired both the targaryen
bloodline and the followers of this
culty religion in essos so raniero
ultimately concedes to wed leonore but
only viserys removes his hand otto from
the high council and since viserys has
been slowly losing his literal hand over
these four episodes it seems inevitable
that this would happen renera and damon
were successful in removing their most
effective obstacle to the throne otto
hightower but house side towers got more
tricks up their sleeve i'm sure but if
the maesters have been part of a
deliberate plot of medical malpractice
we should be concerned about this holy
hand grenade of plan bt that mello
springs ronira to prevent a pregnancy
from daemon but considering daemon was
impotent rainer would not need this for
damon but what about forester kristen
has her masquerade truly worked if the
king still thinks she's soldered herself
enough to need this i think what scares
reneering here is that through her
political victory she has still outed
herself as an impure game player and she
no longer has that shield of innocence
to hide behind thank you so much for
supporting these analyses every week i
swear i really do spend a lot of time
watching and re-watching and re-watching
to try to analyze the visuals to give
you the best product i can so the fact
that you're so patient with me every
week just means the world and thank you
you can follow me on tick tock instagram
and twitter at ea boss follow new
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you